all right you think you know a lot about
our planet Earth well then you should
know true or false the first layer of
Earth is called the mantle
no that's false the first layer of Earth
is called the crust followed by the
mantle followed by the outer core and
then the inner core true or false the
Caspian Sea is the largest sea in the
world
oh that's false too the Caspian Sea is
the largest inland body of water but
it's neither a sea nor a lake big a c is
the Philippine Sea true or false there
are seven continents on earth
[Music]
well that's true there are seven
continents on earth now 200 million
years ago we were all together in one
continent called Pangea true or false
Mount Everest is the highest mountain on
Earth
yeah that's true Mount Everest is the
highest mountain on Earth it's 8 849
meters high how'd you do let us know in
the comments below